WESLEY CHUN: Hey everyone,
this is Wesley Chun,
an engineer and developer
advocate here at Google.
If you've been wanting to
integrate Google technologies
into the apps that
you create, this
is the right place
to get started.
In this episode, we'll
cover the setup process
when you want to build an
app that uses Google APIs.
First of all, why Google
Developer Tools at all?
Well, in the last
episode-- click
the link if you missed
it-- we mentioned
that people are familiar
with tools like Google Search
and YouTube.
But can you imagine having
to create your own Google
Maps or Google Drive?
Well, we can't either.
There's no need to
reinvent these wheels when
you can use our APIs and open
source developer tools to tap
into these technologies.
Today, we'll show you how
easy it is to get started.
You'll learn how to create
a project in the Developer
Console-- or
DevConsole-- and how
to enable the APIs
you wish to use.
Finally, you'll learn how to get
the credentials your app needs
to access Google
APIs, whether you're
accessing authorized data
or using simple API keys
to access public data.
In upcoming episodes,
we'll create
scripts using these credentials
to access Google APIs.
This common code will be
the same regardless of app,
how may APIs it uses,
or what language.
By the way, if you're not
accessing authorized data,
the required code
is even shorter.
Your code will be able to access
Google services from anywhere,
whether it's a client-side
web app, a mobile app,
or a back-end service
running in the cloud.
Because the approach to
all are very similar.
All you need to do to get set
up is done in the browser.
So let's go to the computer now.
All right, here we go.
Any time you're running an app
using Google APIs or the Google
Cloud Platform, you need to
go to the Developer's Console,
or DevConsole.
So pop open a browser to
console.developers.google.com
and log in with your credentials
if you haven't already.
If you don't have a
Google account yet,
then click on the
Create Account link
that you see just
below to get started.
Once you're logged
in, you'll be brought
to the DevConsole's
home page, which
is an overview of
all of your projects.
Don't worry if you
haven't created one yet.
It'll just be blank instead
of having a list of them.
Here, we're going to
be doing three things.
One is to create a new project.
Two is to turn on
the APIs you're
going to use for that project.
And three, you're going
to create and download
the appropriate credentials.
To begin, let's create a project
by clicking on the blue Create
Project button.
You need to provide two things.
One is the project
name, which is
used only here in
the DevConsole--
so you can change it later
if you don't like it.
The second thing you need
to provide is a project ID.
This uniquely
identifies your project
over all the others
in the system.
And because of that, you can't
change it later, so make it
a good one.
For your convenience, Google
creates a random one for you,
like the one you see here.
If you don't like it, pick
your own, if it hasn't already
been chosen, or click on the
little refresh wheel over here,
and Google will make
another random one for you.
Once you've decided,
click on Create.
A bunch of gears will start
spinning around inside Google
data centers to
create your project.
It usually takes
about half a minute
to get the project set up.
Once it's ready, you'll be
taken to your new project's
dashboard, which is
where we'll pick up.
So go ahead and
pause the video to do
that, then resume once you've
landed on your new project's
homepage.
Great, our project was
created successfully.
So here we are on our
project's Overview page.
To keep things
simple, our project
will just be a
command line script.
It could be also a mobile client
or a server-side app running
in the cloud.
We'll show you where those
other options come in later.
For now, the next step
is to enable APIs.
And yes, there is
an app for that,
which is this Enable
an API button.
You'll be taken to the
services page, where
you can turn on APIs
you wish to use.
You'll see that some Google
Cloud Platform services have
already been enabled by default.
So if you're not
interested in using them,
feel free to toggle them
off using the switches
that you see here on
the right-hand side.
Now it's time to find the
APIs that you want to enable.
For example, if you're
interested in using the Google
Drive API, just scroll
down and flip it on.
There it is.
Next, let's say you wanted
the YouTube data API.
Well, you'd scroll down
to find that and turn it
on in the same way that you
would turn on any other API.
Once you're done selecting
the APIs that you wish to use,
scroll back up to the top
to ensure that they've
been turned on,
like we see here.
Now let's set up our credentials
by selecting that link
on the left.
On this page, we see two
sections-- authorized
and public API access.
We're going to create
credentials for both.
For Google Drive,
you should recognize
that files and
folders are user data,
meaning that your app needs to
be authorized in order to get
access to that type of data.
So let's do that by clicking
on the Create New Client ID
button.
Here, we see a dialogue to
enter our application type.
Since it's a simple
command line script,
it's neither a web app nor an
app running on a Google server
acting on behalf
of a user, which
is what a service
account is for.
Instead, we're creating an
installed app, so select that.
Now, it's neither a web
nor a mobile installed app,
but a command line
script instead.
So that means Other.
Now click Create Client
ID to generate your OAuth
credentials.
The last step in this section
is to click on the Download JSON
button.
This will save the credentials
file that your script will
use in order to
communicate with Google
Service for authorization.
Naturally, we'll recommend
you drop that file
into the same folder as to where
you're going to build your app,
like we did here.
So now that's done.
Going back and
taking a look here
at the second half of
the Credentials page,
we see this is for simple or
public API access, meaning
you'll be creating an API key.
It's primarily used for
APIs where you're just
accessing the service, like
searching for YouTube videos.
In such cases, just
having an API key
is good enough, as there's no
need for authorization here.
Click on the Create
New Key button.
Again, we have just a
command line script,
which is neither a
web nor a browser app.
So it's technically a
server app, so select that.
You can also choose to whitelist
IP addresses if you wish.
Otherwise, click Create.
In a few seconds, you'll
have an API key-- ta-da!
This is a string that you
can copy and paste directly
into your code, which is
fine for experimenting with.
But obviously, this
isn't secure in practice.
So if you're doing
this for production,
make sure you put it
into a secure database
or someplace other than plain
text and code, all right?
Anyway, now you've got
authorized and public API
access.
So our mission in the
DevConsole is complete.
The rest is up you.
All right, now that you've
got a project set up,
you're ready to start coding.
In the next episode, we'll walk
you through the common security
code necessary to
use Google APIs.
Well, that's it for now.
Be sure to bring your
code editors next time.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google, and we'll
see you again soon
on the Launchpad.